L
OUA WENEWE
S GEYOU CK OTRAC
HE.
VING GOOTIME
URE WHTHE R TTIN
SQD, PSENTBY DFT KGS
LI IN E EACH REPT
P.
AME  CONR GERS
ALGSID E MAOF T PEOE,
HE'SOT GNG A INGS
HE JUSGETTGSTARD, TT
HOS  WUGIBO
ETOPTMBOD
OUE LE
>>CO IEANND
LE
CTM A  OEGHW.HELEE
WANTO TE THEWHATHIS ?
THAIS E HAY,DAND
I' HADY N.
HIS GHT RE I THE NDY,
IS IHOW U GE UR
ODIE THIIS HYOU T
I'M ITHE COENTSCONN.
A E EN
OU MGU.U WAG  WAOD
NOLEGE SON.PE FORT TH U GI
AW A IP TLAS GAS
THISHING
ISS A OW, U NER KN,
TOHDOW SRES, OSENY U
E SQD.
THENG UDODEARKENG,
TOOWOR K
DEK Y.THWEGOMAP
NOSUSETHP,PE TA DARE NS AINSTOUT
TE
NICK CHU SITNG ERE,
WA CAM ORGAIN THENTHE.
ISTI CAFFY, WKNOWEN DO
RAVE TE.GAINA DEETED
BACKN TRK? CAHEGET
JOTHAN TLOR,NDGEORTTLE
VIYCAFEE OMLAEE
HEREA OF
DAY  T'S   GET !P  ME!
JUIN JEERSO.
>> JOSH ALLEN FOR THE LOCK!
LET'S GO BABY!
>> LOCK IN, AND CHRISTIAN
MCCAFFREY!
>> KEENAN ALLEN, IT'S A LOCK
BOYS!
>> YOU GOT A LOT OF.
GREG, WE KNOW YOU GOT THE
HOODIES.
BUT WE ARE TAKING THINGS UP A
NOTCH THIS SEASON, BUT ALSO
GONE SCORE FOR THEM.
>> I'M NOT ONLY GIVING OUT
HOODIES, I'M ALSO GIVING OUT 2,
NOT ONE, 2 AND A SELL JERSEY
GIFT CARDS.
ONE IS GOING TO THE WINNER OF
THE LOCK LEGEND CONTEST, THE
OTHER IS GOING TO A COMMENTER.
WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GETTING THE COMMENTS AND DO
WHAT YOU DO!
IF YOU NEED A JERSEY, IF YOU
NEED A HOODIE, I NEED GIFTS I
NEED EMOJIS I NEED COMMENTS.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY!
I NEED WINNERS, WINNERS ONLY
PLEASE!
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE HAVE 4 LEGENDARY PICKS TO
SHOW YOU, AS ALWAYS.
THE LAST ONE STANDING IS THE
LEADER OF THE SQUAD.
THAT PLAYER GETS AN ODDS BOOST
ON DRAFT KINGS.
YOU WILL WANT TO STICK AROUND
TILL THE END AND HAMMER THAT ON
SPOOKED.
IT IS TIME FOR ROUND ONE, AND
WHO BETTER TO START WITH THAN
THE DEFENDING CHAMPS, THE
REIGNING SQUAD LEADER, THAT IS
RILEY'S ARRIVAL.
RILEY, TELL US WHO IS GOING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
>> LAST WEEK DERRICK HENRY
COULDN'T GET IT DONE FOR US,
BUT WE WON 4-0 LAST YEAR ON THE
FARM SO WE ARE BACK IN THE
FORM.
CHECK THIS OUT.
COME ON.
WHICH ONE DO YOU WANT?
WHAT DO YOU GOTTA?
WHY DID YOU GET?
GEORGE KITTLE GEORGE KITTLE.
LOCK IT IN!
>> GOOD BOYS, ONLY PLEASE.
BACK ON THE FARM.
OUR FIRST DECISION OF THE DAY.
THE 2ND LEGEND, THIS ONE COMES
FROM W. TRAMMELL WHAT DO YOU
GOT TRAMMELL!
>> THE OUR NATION.
ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
WE GOTTA.
ALVIN KAMARA.
LOCK IT IN!
>> LOVE THE B/R BRANDING ON THE
BALLOONS!
YOU HEARD THE FIRST 2 PITCHES
HERE.
GREG, WHO ARE YOU RIDING WITH!
YOU GOT CHARLIE ON THE FARM, OR
THE BALLOON LEGEND?
>> CONOR, BEFORE I GIVE MY
TAKE.
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY IN THE
COMMENTS TO DO, TELL US WHO YOU
ARE RIDING WITH.
ARE YOU RIDING WITH REILLY, AND
THE RED LEGEND.
OR ARE YOU RIDING WITH TRAMMELL,
THE BALLOON LEGEND, AND ALVIN
KAMARA.
LET ME TALK ABOUT THESE VIDEOS
A LITTLE BIT, RILEY IS BACK ON
THE FARM.
AS HE MENTIONED HE IS 4-0 ON
AND HE IS BACK ON THE FARM.
I LIKE THAT RIGHT THERE.
ALSO, THAT DOG IS TRYING TO GET
RED LIKE EVERYBODY HERE.
PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS, CONNOR,
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET TO THE
BREAD, AND I'M TRYING TO GET TO
THE.
SO THE DOG TALK TO THE BRAND.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU RILEY, YOU ARE
ONCE AGAIN A LEGEND.
I LOVE THE GEORGE KITTLE THING.
THE BALLOON, THE BRANDING, A
ONE.
THE BUCKET LEGENDS ARE BACK.
THEY ARE LEVELING UP THIS WEEK,
WITH THE SLOW-MO VIDEO.
PUT A LITTLE PRODUCTION INTO
THIS.
ALVIN KAMARA PICKED, OKAY I
LIKE IT.
BUT I'M LEANING TOWARDS GEORGE
KITTLE, LOVE THE BREAD
REFERENCE.
LOVE REILLY ON THE FARM HE IS
FOR NO.
THAT IS WHO I'M ROCKING WITH.
WHO ARE YOU ROCKING WITH CONOR?
>> I LOVE DOC, I LOVE THE
GEORGE KITTLE PICK.
THAT IS PLUS MONEY RIGHT THERE.
BUT I'M A SUCKER FOR BRANDING.
THE B/R BRANDING.
THE BALLOON LEGEND, GOING WITH
ALVIN KAMARA.
BUT IT IS NOT UP TO ME.
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE DECIDING
RIGHT NOW?
>> CONOR, BACK INTO THE HANDY,,
DANDY AND THE COMMENTS ARE
MOVING AT A FAST PACED.
I GOT SAN FRANCE CITY SAYS,
KITTLE ALL THE WAY!
49ERS YOU KNOW THAT'S GONNA GET
MY ATTENTION.
THEREFORE YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH THE HOODIE.
I AM MOVING ON, I SEE HUSHED A
MUST.
IN THE COMMENTS SAYING THE
PEOPLE'S CHAMP, GEORGE KITTLE,
YOU KNOW HE LIKES TO BE THE
PEOPLES TIGHT END.
HE'S ROCKING WITH GEORGE
KITTLE.
CONNOR, THE NEXT ONE I CHOOSE,
I'M JUST GONNA SAY THAT THEY'RE
WINNING.
>> LET'S DO IT!
>> JUST DON'T THINK THAT
UNBIASED.
I'M GONNA PICK AND SCROLL
WHEREVER I LAND, WE'RE GONNA
ROCK WITH YOU.
3, 2, ONE, SQUIRREL, SAM.
KAMARA.
OH BEE PEE WON 9.
YOU GET THE ALVIN KAMARA JEFF
RIGHT HERE.
OBP19 OBP19 YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
>> UPSET AGAINST THE REIGNING
CAN REILLY'S ORBIT.
HOPEFULLY RALLIED BACK NEXT
WEEK WITH CHARLIE.
MOVING ON, ONLY 2 CHALLENGES
REMAIN, LET'S GET YOU TO ROUND
2.
OUR NEXT PICK COMES FROM MARK
BETTER.
WE GOT MARK?
>> THE RACING LEGEND, GOING
WITH TRAVIS KELCE.
MAN I HAVE TO GET ONE OF THOSE
IN MY HOUSE.
I LOVE THE PONIES IN THIS ONE
RIGHT NOW.
GREG, ARE YOU GOING WITH THE
RACING LEGEND?
OR ARE YOU STICKING WITH THE
BALLOONS?
>> I NEED EVERYBODY TO TELL US,
WHO WILL WIN THIS PORTION OF
THE CONTEST.
I NEED EVERYBODY IN THE
COMMENTS, SHOULD I ROCK WITH
THE RACE LEGEND, OR THE BALLOON
LEGEND.
I WILL GIVE MY TAKE ON THE RACE
LEGENDS.
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN IT BEFORE,
THIS WAS ACTUALLY ENTERTAINING.
THAT NUMBER 5 HORSE, LOOKS LIKE
HE MIGHT HAVE BEEN ON P.E.D.S,
THE WAY HE GOT OFF THE BLOCK.
WE NIGHT SEEN TO HIS SON
SOMEDAY OUT THEIR EGO TEST AND.
TRAVIS KELCE, PATRICK MAHOMES
IS MY FANTASY QUARTERBACK.
THERE IS A CONNECTION THERE.
I'M LEANING TOWARDS THE RIGHTS
LEGEND.
I LIKE THE VIDEO, I LIKE THE
PICK.
WHERE ARE YOU LEANING CONOR?
>> I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU, I
LOVE THIS PICK.
TRAVIS KELCE SCORES AT LEAST
ONCE ON SUNDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL.
LOVE THE PONIES MAN, LOVE THE
CONCEPT, HAVEN'T SEEN IT
BEFORE.
IT'S CREATIVE.
I THINK WE DO NEED TO HAVE SOME
P.E.D. TEST REGULATION HERE, IF
NUMBER 5 KEEPS WINNING.
ONCE AGAIN, NOT UP TO ME, TO
THE COMMENTS HAVE A FAVORITE?
TO THE BALLOON LEGEND GET
KNOCKED OFF AND ROW NUMBER 2.
>> LET ME FIND OUT, CONOR.
I GOT SEE LOW ZERO 3-3.
WITH THE TRAVIS KELCE GIVE IT
JUST ONE AWAY.
I CAN'T TELL YOU GUESS, BUT HE
TRICKED TRAVIS KELCE.
I ALSO HAVE G H GUNS BURGER,
THAT IS FOR THE PRODUCERS.
HE HAS THE TRAVIS KELCE GIFTED
SYNCING AS WELL.
>> CONOR I THINK IT'S TIME TO
MAKE A DECISION, BIG MIKE SAYS
TRAVIS KELCE THE COMMENTS
MOVING I CAN'T EVEN SHOW YOU
GUYS GIF, MY GUY MARK BEN HAVE,
AND TRAVIS KELCE IS MOVING ON
TO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> I THINK IT WAS MADE EASY FOR,
YOU MARK VANNA MOVING ON, THE
PONIES MOVING ON.
TRAVIS KELCE, ARE YOU GETTING
IN ON SPRUCE THIS WEEK?
HE'LL HAVE TO DEFEAT OUR FINAL
CONTENDER.
TO TAKE HOME THE JERSEY.
IF YOU WANT TO JERSEY STICK
AROUND, BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE TO
GIVE AWAY AS WELL.
THE WINNER OF THIS ROUND NEXT
UP, LAST, UP IS OSCAR
PARKINSON.
OSCAR, LET'S SEE THE PICK.
CAN YOU CLOSE THIS OUT?
>> I MIGHT PRACTICE FINISH
COOKING UP, THESE ARE SIZZLING.
ALL RIGHT, DALLAS?
WHAT DO WE GOT ZEKE 80 YARDS?
NO.
ARIZONA, KATE MURRAY 50 RUSH
YARDS?
NO.
>> GREEN BAY, DEE ADAMS?
90 YARDS?
NOT AFTER LAST WEEK.
CAROLINA, CMC, ANYTIME, TD,
LOCK.
RIGHT HERE GUYS, CMC, ANYTIME.
LOCK IT IN!
>> LOVE WHAT HE IS COOKING UP,
LOVE THE PICKS.
CMC, TRAVIS KELCE, YOU GET A
GOOD BOOST SOMEWHERE.
GREG, WHICH WHY DO YOU WANT
THIS ON THE?
GO >> CONOR, LET ME ASK PEOPLE
IN THE AUDIENCE FIRST.
WE GOT TRAVIS KELCE, CHRISTIAN
MCCAFFREY.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU GUYS LEANING?
DO YOU LIKE THE RACE, LEGENDARY
LIKE THE OVEN LEGEND?
LET ME HOP IN HERE ON THE HANDY,
DANDY.
CONNOR, I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW THE WORD I'M
TRYING TO SAY.
I THOUGHT I WOULD SEE SOMETHING
TASTY, I THOUGHT I WOULD SEE
SOMETHING SIZZLING, COMING OUT
THE OVEN.
I SAW, NO.
I DON'T KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT
THE.
I THINK I'M STILL LEANING
HORSES, TRAVIS KELCE, AND THE
RACE LEGEND.
AND THE PD HORSE OUT THE BOX
REALLY FAST.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA LEAN THIS
WAY.
WHICH WHERE ARE YOU?
>> I'M GONNA BE HONEST WITH YOU,
I'M COMFORTABLE SITTING ON THE
FENCE HERE.
I THINK BOTH OF THESE GUYS GO
THIS WEEK.
WHICHEVER ONE WIN, I WILL
HAPPILY HAMMER.
TRAVIS KELCE ON SUNDAY NIGHT
FOOTBALL, CMC AGAINST THE
SAINTS.
WE KNOW DEROGATORY CHECKING IT
DOWN ALL DAY.
WHO'S GONNA BE THE SQUAD LEADER
IN WEEK 2.
>> CONOR, LET ME TAP INTO THE
HANDY, DANDY.
I MEAN, I AM SEEING A LOT, AND
A LOT OF YOUR GUY CMC.
I GOT I AS H AI, THAT'S FOR THE
PRODUCER.
ROCKING WITH CMC, GAVE ME THE
CMC GIF.
TO SEE HIM SEE RIGHT THERE.
SHOUT OUT TO DANIEL GOTTMAN,
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'M GONNA GIVE AWAY ONE MORE, I
GOT CHRIS PARGO, HE GOT THE CMC
GIF GOING.
I AM SEEING A LANDSLIDE, CMC
GIF, CMC COMMENTS, YEAH WE ARE
MAKING THE CALL.
IT'S OVER THE OVEN LEGEND IS
WINNING TODAY'S CONTEST.
HE HAS WON, THE PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN.
SHOUT OUT TO CMC ANY OF
ENLARGING.
LET.
SEE THE GRAPHIC I HAVE TO SHOW
YOU GET SOMETHING, US ON THE
SQUAD, SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO
ONLY.
- 1-50.
CONOR, LET ME SHOW YOU SOME
MAGIC POOF!
YOU JUST SAW THAT IT JUST
CHANGED TO + 100.
THANKS TO OUR FRIENDS A
DRAFTKINGS, WE ARE GONNA BOOST
THAT RIGHT NOW FOR YOU GUYS
CHECK OUT THE LINKS FOR THE ON
BOOST.
CHECK OUT YOUR BETS.
SEND US THE VIDEOS OF YOUR
CELEBRATIONS.
WE WANT WINNERS, AND WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE!
LET'S GO A.B.!
THAT JUST PUMP ME UP.
>> THAT IS A BEAUTIFUL SIGHT, I
LOVE IT!
BEAUTIFUL SIGHT TO SEE CMC PLUS
MONEY.
WE ARE NOT DONE, WE GOT MORE
LOCKS TO GIVE, WE GOT MORE GOLD
BETS.
YOU GOT MORE HOODIES, YOU EVEN
GOT A JERSEY!
WHERE IS THIS JERSEY GONNA GO?
I JUST CAN'T WAIT, IF YOU HANG
OUT IN THE B/R COMMUNITY
WHETHER IT'S ON THE APP, ON
SOCIAL, YOU KNOW WHAT WE ASK
YOU ON THE BATS.
WE WANT YOUR BOLDEST BETS.
CALVIN RIDLEY, WATER SEAVER,
TITANS COMING OUT THEY ARE
SEATED LOOK WEAK ONE.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE BOLD,
THESE ARE NOT SET BETS, THESE
ARE BOLD.
TRYING TO HAVE A GOOD TIME.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU THINK.
GREG, LET'S SEE WHAT PEOPLE HAD
TO SAY FOR WEEK 2.
>> I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET INTO
THE COMMENTS, AND TELL ME WHICH
ARE THESE THE BEST TAKES.
I'M GOING TO GIVE A HOODIE TO
WHOMEVER YOU GUYS CHOOSE.
I WANNA SHOW YOU 3 COMMENTS,
THIS WEEK FIRST IS MY GUY MATH
DAD FURRED.
LET'S PULL IT UP, THERE IT IS.
MATT GAFFORD SAYS, THAT MY WIFE
COMES BACK HOME.
+ 9000.
>> LONG SHOT.
>> MATT, I'M GONNA SEND YOU A
HOODIE.
JUST TO KEEP YOU WARM AT NIGHT.
NEXT IS KYLE 1-3, THAT PACKERS
WILL CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE 0-2.
MOVE, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT
ONE.
FINALLY RAIDER OH 9, SAYS
DERRICK ARE FOR ANOTHER 400
YARDS 3 TOUCHDOWNS AGAINST THE
STEELERS DEFENSE.
!
WHAT ARE YOU KIDDING ME!
CONOR, WHICH TAKE DO YOU THINK
IS THE BEST.
I'M OVER HERE SWEAT AND WRITERS
9 OH 9 COMMENTS.
>> WE SAID BOLD BETS, NOT
INSANE.
I KNOW THEY'RE RAIDER FANS, I'M
SORRY.
COMING OFF A FUN WEEK.
I HOPE IT HAPPENS FOR A.
I THINK IT WOULD TAKE EVEN A
WIN, OR COVER.
400 YARDS, 3 TOUCHDOWNS.
IT'S DARREN WALLER GONNA HAVE
300 OF THEM?
I'M NOT LOVING THAT, I ALREADY
SAID THE WIFE TO COME HOME +
9000, SORRY I'M OUT OF THAT.
IF I HAD TO PICK ONE OF THESE 3,
ALL ROLL WITH THAT.
IT'S GONNA BE A TOUGH REBUILD
FOR THE LIONS, BUT DAN CAMPBELL
HAVE THEM READY TO PLAY.
PACKERS, I THINK THEY BOUNCE
BACK THIS WEEK.
BUT LET'S GO WITH THE BOLDEST
BAT, FROM MY.
AND TAKING THE LIONS.
WHY DID THE PEOPLE SAY?
TO THE PEOPLE AGREE WITH ANY OF
THESE?
>> DIDI T SAYS PACKERS SAY 0-2.
HE IS ROCKING WITH THE D
CONNOR.
LET ME GIVE YOU HOODIE DITZY.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
NEIL 40-40, PACKERS PACK IT IN
AND HAVE A MISERABLE SEASON.
GO PACK GO!
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
THEY ARE WALK-IN WITH CONOR,
THE WINNER, OF THIS CONTEST,
IT'S KYLE WON 3-3.
WITH THE PACKERS TAKE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU KYLE WE WILL
BE SENDING YOU HOODIE.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I JUST
MENTION.
YOU ARE ALSO WALKING AWAY WITH
A HOODIE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, YOU KNOW THAT
WE CAN'T STAY WAY FROM THE
BOLDEST BETS.
WE GET IT ON THE PHONE, AND
GIVE OUR BALD SPOTS.
MY FAVORITE PART OF THE WEEK.
WHEN THINGS GET CRAZY.
THIS IS WHEN WE NEED THE PEOPLE
THE MOST.
EVEN MORE THAN A SQUAD RIDE
LATER.
WHAT WE NEED FROM THEM RIGHT
NOW BREAK?
>> SO LISTEN, EVERYBODY,
EVERYBODY LISTEN UP.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME,
WHETHER YOU ARE RIDING WITH ME
OR CONOR.
GREG, OR CONOR.
IN THE COMMENTS ONLY.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHICH WAY
YOU GOTTA FIGURE.
CONNOR, WHO DO YOU HAVE THIS
WEEK HAS YOUR BALL DISPATCH,
RATHER?
>> YOU KNOW LAST WEEK, I'M ON A
5 WAY PARLAY.
A COUPLE HITS, MANY DID NOT.
I GOT A LITTLE AMBITIOUS.
I DON'T HAVE KIDS TO FEED.
BUT STILL, I'M SHAVING A LITTLE
OFF BECAUSE IT WAS JUST TOO
NUTS.
GO ON WITH A 4 WAY PARLAY
TODAY.
+ 5-66.
BIG TIME LONG SHOT.
CHASE CLAYPOOL OVER 3 AND A
HALF RECEPTIONS.
IN THAT GREATER SECONDARY, NOT
WHERE THEY'RE.
BILLS MONEY LINE, SOMETHING YOU
ARE NOT A PLANNED ALL WEEK.
BILLS TOUGH WEEK ONE, BIG
BOUNCE BACK AGAINST MIAMI.
I LIKE THE BILLS TO WIN.
TEXANS, BROWNS OVER 48.
I KNOW PEOPLE ARE NOT REALLY
COUNTING ON THE TEXANS DOING
THEIR SCORING AND THIS ONE.
I THINK TYROD TAYLOR AND
BRANDON COOKS GET ENOUGH, WHILE
THE BROWNS HIGH POWERED OFFENSE
CARRIES IT WELL.
48 IS REALLY NOT A HIGH NUMBER.
THEY SHOULD BE THE LOCK IN THE
PARLAY.
IF THIS DOESN'T WIN, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I HAVE TO DO.
BRONCOS MONEY LINE OVER
JACKSONVILLE.
LIKE I SAID THOSE PACKAGES ARE
GOING TO GET HOME.
MAKING IT A TOUGH DAY FOR THE
SENSATIONAL ROOKIE TREVOR
LAWRENCE.
HAD A TOUGH WEEK ONE, HE'S
GONNA FIGURE IT OUT.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL BE THIS
WEEK.
I WANT TO HEAR YOURS.
I'M AN ADDICT TO THIS, FUN WHEN
YOU THROW A LITTLE MONEY ON.
LET'S HEAR WHAT YOU HAVE AS
WELL.
>> I GOT, YOU CONOR, I GOT YOU.
LET'S PULL UP THIS GRAPHIC, I
CAN SHOW THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMENTS, AND MY GUY CONOR
RODGERS WHAT WE ARE ROCKING
WITH TODAY.
SHOUT OUT TO MY GUY CHAD
JOHNSON + 85.
I GOT THE NINERS, TAKING ON THE
EAGLES.
I JUST TOOK THE WIN, I TOOK THE
SPREAD LAST WEEK THEY DID NOT
COVER AGAINST THE LIONS.
FORGET ABOUT THAT, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS WEEK.
THE EAGLES FACE THE ATLANTA
FALCONS LAST WEEK.
A LOT OF OVERREACTION ON HOW
THEY PLAYED.
THE NINERS WILL HANDLE
BUSINESS.
LET'S MOVE ON CONNOR, WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT A.
BUFFALO BILLS, WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING IT SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THIS WEEK IN FACT.
WE ARE ROCKING WITH THAT, WE
ARE STAYING WITH THE BUFFALO
BILLS.
MOVING ON TO THE CINCINNATI
BENGALS, WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHO'S GONNA BE PLAYING
QUARTERBACK FOR CHICAGO.
I JUST GOT AN ALERT THAT MY GUY
FIELD, MIGHT TAKE THE FIELD
TODAY.
I DO NOT KNOW WHO IS GONNA BE
PLAYING, SO I'M GOING TO ROCK
WITH THE BENGALS.
I KNOW WHO WILL BE PLAYING
QUARTERBACK FOR THEM.
MOVING ON TO THE SAINTS, I AM
SIMPLY BETTING AGAINST SAM
DARNOLD.
I DO NOT THINK HE IS GOING TO
WIN A GAME AGAINST THAT
DEFENSE.
I BET THAT HE CAN WIN A GAME
AGAINST THAT SAME DEFENSE.
I CALL THIS THE OLD JOE
FAITHFUL.
SHOUT OUT TO MY GUY.
FAVORITE PARLAY, WITH THE PLUS
MONEY BANGER.
THERE IT IS YOUNG!
LOCKETT ENCOUNTER!
>> WHO ARE THE PEOPLE RIDING
WITH, AND I KNOW YOU HAVE TO
GET RID OF THIS JERSEY BEFORE
WE GET OUT HERE.
>> CONNOR, THEY WERE SAYING
CRYING BEFORE I EVEN GAVE MY
PICK.
>> THEY DON'T LIKE MINE OFF THE
JUMP!
>> LET ME JUST GIVE AWAY SOME
HOODIES, FOR THE VIBES, AND THE
LOVE.
IT'S ALL OF, HERE ON THE SQUAD
RIDE SHOW.
GREGORY, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
THEY ARE ALL SAYING GRONK, I'M
JUST TRYING TO READ SOMETHING.
DICK GEEK.
THEY ARE SAYS CALM IT'S BETTER.
CONNOR, GUESS BY TRYING TO GIVE
AWAY THE JERSEY.
THEY TELL ME IN MY EAR
GIVEAWAY.
PURPLE AND GOLD 19 HAS A GIF
THAT SAYS MY NAME ON IT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, IT'S THE
CREATIVITY THAT I'M ROCKING
WITH.
THEREFORE, PURPLE AND GOLD,
THOSE ARE MY HIGH SCHOOL
COLORS.
HE ♪MIGHT WANT TO MY HOUSE-%p S